ireland's only cable car isn't for the
faint-hearted
passengers to dursey island are
suspended 250 meters above the atlantic
ocean
sometimes they feel they need a bit of
luck here we have our our our little
bottle of holy water for look and our
our good luck charm here i suppose
it's kept us going for the last
50 60 odd years
kept kept look with us but now the cable
car has closed for much needed repairs
shutting off the lifeline for at least
nine months
dursee island is at the very southwest
tip of ireland jutting out into the
atlantic the strong tides make regular
ferries impossible so it's been
connected by a cable car since 1969
while it's not supposed to take sheep
anymore the two permanent residents and
the eight farmers do use it every day
when we arrived they were worried and
angry
i mean our entire way of life and making
a living has been
on on the cusp of being taken from us
i mean we're on the eve of closure now
and
look i mean
what can i say it's shocking but while
we were filming we got a phone call from
a government source in dublin at the
last minute a replacement ferry would
now be funded and we were able to give
the news to joe so is this a good day
then
it is it is it's a much better evening
than it was morning anyway that's for
sure you said you hadn't been sleeping
with the worry no i have not no no i
mean the devil is going to be here i
mean if we do
push on and if the ferry and money's
fire ferry are granted that will be
fantastic it seemed a solution had been
found at the last moment but people who
often feel marginalized by authorities
were still unhappy at how the saga had
unfolded what's your take on the
situation well my take on it is nobody
has a problem with it closing down
everybody knows the toes need to be
replaced but it's the way they've gone
about things
i mean
there should have been there had to be a
prior notice that this was going to
happen
there aren't many votes on dursey we
were told
but there are real people and real lives
and they're waiting to hear how they'll
be reconnected while their iconic cable
car is gone
stephen murphy sky news on dersi island